world
so we want to make sure that we spread
that light and let that light and make
sure our door is open
to anyone um so getting that uci license
kind of legitimizes kind of what we're
doing on a pro level
um and now we have you know pro-american
black riders that are back into that
that that level
of racing again so um we'll see how it
goes
it's really exciting it's something that
i i wasn't expecting you know like for
me it was more about
you know really staying focused on
growing a different type of
event that could basically not challenge
but
could be next to a different a different
avenue
for for guys that didn't really didn't
want to go over to europe or
couldn't make it in europe um and and
that's what we
that's what we started but everything
evolves and and i'm really
happy and proud to have that uci license
and to be recognized
global cycling body that's fantastic so
are you going to focus strictly with
your new team maybe you can give us some
of the names of the riders as well but
will you focus strictly on crit racing
or
will you do some road racing as well or
will you even go into cyclone across
over a mountain like that
we do a little bit everything we just
like to win so it's about having fun
and winning uh whatever we enter into
anything we we throw guys into we'll
make sure that they have the proper
support to
to not only have fun but to give it
their best um so we have uh
lance haydick who's an under 23 cross
rider he did pretty well i think he was
fourth in the last
championship we had and he's really good
he's gonna do some some cross stuff some
gravel stuff
um and then we have a bunch of really
good uh road riders that want to come
over and
there's there's some road races here
that's some stage races here that suit
us like joe martin
uh there's joe martin um there's a
couple of other ones we got into the uci
race that's happening in baltimore
last year but it was going to be this
like circus to try to figure out how to
get a domestic elite team in
so getting the new license makes that
easier um we're looking at the tour
britain that would be amazing to come
over
uh there's a massive you know black
community there
that we wanna i was talking to kav the
other day and he was saying how um
the neighborhood that the track is in uh
there's a
there's a uh the neighborhoods that are
that are surrounding it are
of people of color um and he would love
help uh in in
introducing them to a track that's
basically lives in their neighborhood
um that they may or may not know exist
doing sore brain that would that would
really um
um cause um a lot of
enthusiasm in the uk and i think the
track you might be thinking of maybe the
hern hill velodrome in london
is that because they're not
gone i've i've and not in the track but
outside of the track funny enough when
we're doing
your stuff with uh with alec briggs
who's my guy
um when i come down but yeah it's i
think that's all he's talking about
yeah that's the one and that's that's
the track where morris
um i did yeah but you started from isn't
it maurice that's your that's your old
hunting
dude 50 years ago madam
50 years ago
in fact i sent a birthday celebration
birthday wishes to
one of the coaches he was 80 years old
today
bob addy he's in australia now he was in
the holdsworth
professional team and he was one of the
coaches at hearn hill when i started
racing
um 50 years ago and i always remember he
was always
he always used to shout at us you know
keep your hands on the bottom of the
handlebars
yeah that was that was 50 years ago it
was uh when i started at home hill
and i always remember the the coach the
main
the first one bill dodds he said to us
what inspired me was
he said to before the first time we went
there we weren't allowed to ride
that day we had to listen to the to the
um to the coach and he said
from here you can go to the olympic
games and um
yeah that was um that was all that's all
i needed to know because i knew that i
had some talent
but i didn't know how to how to move
forward with that talent you know
and um and that was that's what that's
what started me off
yeah yeah and you
and you did i wanted to win um
three national championships as part of
um
well i mean you start you started you
started off with the villain club of
london the vcl and you won the junior
national championships
and then you were able to go and race
for
great um for england at the commonwealth
games in 74.
um what happened with that marlon was
that um
was that the coach at the time was that
was a man called norman shiel and norman
norman was
was a previous um world pursuit champion
and um he he he took a liking to me from
the from the first time he saw me his
his eyes look like they
popped out with his head i went to
leicester and
you know he saw that there was something
there and
i wanted the junior sprint and so by
default he said whoever won that junior
sprint was going to be
having us was going gonna go to the
commonwealth games and so
that's what happened unfortunately by
the time the games came around
norman departed from british cycling and
went off to canada
and so the new people who took over um
they didn't quite like me in the same
way that that norman did and
and to be honest with you as far as my
memory serves me i don't think i ever
represented
um england or great britain again
in the age of um from the age i was
selected i was 17 years old and i was
selected and i was 18 by the time i went
there
so the second british championship that
i won
was actually after the commonwealth
games and what i did
to win that championship was i beat the
gold and silver medalist from the
commonwealth games to win the british
title
and so yeah what can i say it's um
i wasn't all together too bad it
i think there's a similarity in um
justin's
early um track cycling pursuits because
didn't you um clean up a little bit when
you're a junior as well justin
um i was um
i was doing a lot of criteriums and road
stuff when i was a junior i did
a year about a year and a half of road
racing before i got on the track and
then when i got on the
track my first two events was just the
california state championship in the
national championship so i was kind of
thrown in the fire
um but i got good at it pretty quickly
um
the same kind of deal i think that the
the structure
that usa cycling is here was really
interesting because
you know when i was 16 i think i won
like 15 cat 3 races and i remember you
know they were sending out newsletters
about kids getting like top five and cat
three races
and i was just like very confused on
what you know why these newsletters were
going out
about guys that were getting podiums
when i was winning those races
um so i you know i was for sure i was
like oh i'm gonna be on a national team
for sure
you know i'm winning all these races
they obviously noticed them because
they're
sending out stuff uh and 17 is the first
year you can you know you can get on
that team and wear that jersey so i
thought it was for sure gonna happen
and nothing happened like i was very
confused like nothing happened
i ended up having to reach out and uh
i had to reach out and you know as a kid
not everyone's gonna know this you know
not
and most kids shouldn't have to like
most kids shouldn't have to know this if
there's a
if you're developing talent and you're
looking for talent throughout
the best of the best throughout the
country you know there should be people
scouting
for those those riders and it just
wasn't a thing um
so yeah same kind of same kind of story
i got on the the track team because i
won
nationals and that was the first contact
that i had with the national team after
winning
um and then you know i wanted to do road
and track and
they were only interested in me doing
the track yeah
you know and it just you know i felt
like i had talent in sprinting and road
sprinting and navigating finishes and i
wanted to
you know win win a lot of the classics
and and and
sprint on the chance to listen and so on
and so forth uh
and like yeah they kind of just killed
that dream and made me a
and say you're a track rider do track um
and then it was the same thing that was
a coach that was there um
that you know i got into madison stuff
and started slowly switching over to
endurance on the track and doing pursuit
and stuff
um yeah he set me up he set me up to
basically
go race in europe on the national team
to get some
to basically get beat on so that i could
get stronger and i could get a tough
mentally tougher get into that headspace
of those longer races
holding power for long and all that
stuff and saying he he
he went somewhere else i think he went
to australia and then after that i
never never had contact with the
national team after that
yeah it seems to me that that
relationship that
is you know struck with a coach or you
know that
engagement that you have with with a
national coach can really
um influence um the trajectory you know
your
the route that you you take as a cyclist
where you're gonna go down
that route of representing your country
whether you're going to be um
sidelined and i've certainly um
found out quite a lot through my
research that that that there is a big
influence of that national coaching
determining um your career path
as a as a cyclist which is really
interesting
and i see that you mentioned um going to
europe because
one thing that i found that through my
research and looking into your
stories is that you both went over to
europe at the age of 19 around that and
you
and you um you know you're a young
you're a young black athlete cyclist
feeling the force of your power
and you go there i mean what the hell
are you doing i mean
leaving your family and going to europe
and i mean what what what what what did
your parents think morris what did you
your dad think well marlon to be honest
with you
um what happened was it's a funny thing
but the the guy who i
my shop that i've got now diverse cycles
the man's name was peter burleston he
was an australian
and he called it and now before he had
that shot
he came to europe his aspirations were
to become a professional sixth day rider
he was a few years older than me maybe
three years older than me i don't know
anyway i heard he was going to belgium
so i said to him
i i said can i come with you the reason
the reason i went there in the first
place is because
it's because i had um i had an
invite to go and ride in trinidad and
barbados
in 1975
and um it was february march february
and march
1975 and so i
knew that i needed to have some kind of
i needed to be in shape for this for
these races especially
owing to the fact that when i went in
in um december 74 for my
national drama to collect my trophy for
winning the national championships
um there's the people there the
officials
were taken aback by the fact that i was
going to trinidad and barbados and they
there aren't their words to me were
well you know we didn't select you so
you can't wear great britain jersey
so of course you know bearing in mind
i'd just turn 19
and um this is what they told me and so
i thought well you know what i'm going
to make sure i do well when i go out
there
so i knew i needed to have some kind of
shape be in shape to go out there
so when this guy was telling me he was
going to belgium i said you know what
i'm coming with you
and what it was marlon i had two weeks
holiday from work
i was an apprentice electrician i just
started
i've been left school and i've been one
year as an
apprentice electrician and at that point
i knew that i was pretty good in england
but whether i could cut it in belgium
was another story
and so i thought to myself i've got two
weeks holiday
i've gotta find out if i can if i'm good
i'm gonna be a pro rider if i'm not good
i'm gonna be an electrician
and um well you know there's comes a
point in
in life where you've got to make a
decision because you can't
you can't be doing both you can't be
doing well you see you're
either going to be one thing or if
you're going to be an electrician that's
fine you take cycling as a hobby
on the other hand if you want to be a
professional rider then then that's it
you've got to it's got to be a hundred
percent
and i went to belgium and um it's a
funny thing but that the man who the the
person in charge of the velodrome
his name was oscar damas and that man
again he took a liking to me
and in fact to the point where the
the last race i rode in february before
before the end of the winter season
there was two races for amateurs that
day and he said to me
he said you know what mauricio said i'm
going to give you a kado
akado is a is a gift it's a it's a
present
in french so what he did he put all the
good riders in one race and put and put
everyone else in the other race with me
and he said so i couldn't lose the race
that was the encouragement he gave me to
come back next winter
the riding that happened to sixth day
and so that's that's how it all started
for me
in belgium you know it was it was a
positive thing it was definitely a
positive thing and i felt
the crowd and the people there um i seem
to appreciate
which was a difference from from me when
i won that national championship the
second one
you know and i held up those flowers you
know there were people in the crowd who
were booing you know
which didn't affect me too much but all
the same
i felt in belgium that um that there was
more i was more appreciated to put it
that way
yeah yeah and justin um
your time in belgium a different era of
course um
but are there any sort of learning
points or any you know
you know what what were two highs and
what you know and one learning point
that you could take away from your
experiences
racing on the continent yeah no it was
um
it was just really hard i just remember
every race being hard
i remember being in a um in a race uh
that started so fast that it was
circuits right so it started so fast
that i was
sure like they were going to slow down
the next lot i was like just
just make it one more lap they're going
to slow down just make a woman we're
going to slow down and it never it
slowed down for like
like 10 minutes with like you know maybe
20k to go
and that was the break i got um it just
yeah it's really opened my eyes
um belgium and racing they really opened
my eyes it was it was different i was
you know i was from l.a and i was a
pretty shy kid because
you know we grew up having to be very
careful about what was going on
um just because of the environment that
we're in so
i was really shy i wasn't you know i
wasn't very social like
coming over and being an american was
like really different and it was already
like in my head i was like
everyone knows you're american so like
there's these these things that like
they're already expecting um and it was
funny because like you know people would
come up to me and like complain to me
about teammates
and i'd be like dude like i don't i
don't know
what you want from me i guess i'm not
the one that's screaming back so they
were like maybe this one's reasonable
but i'm just going to ask you as well i
mean
about your parents impressions you know
maurice you know what did your dad say
about you going over there and justin
what were your parents forced about you
as you know this young
going over there leaving home and go and
say my
my parents milan i have to i have to let
you know that i mean
when i won that second national
championship i don't think my parents
had actually seen me ride a bike at that
point
i know that he was on television and my
and my
and a friend a good friend of mine
phoned up my parents just tell them to
let them know us their son was on the
television
and i don't know to this day i don't
know if my dad ever saw it because i
know he was a fan of the rescue
and the wrestling was on the other
channel so i don't really know but
um you know what i just i just looked at
my parents and i just said
i just said mom dad i'm going to i'm
going to belgium now you know and that
that's kind of they said okay you know
and i don't i win
i didn't i didn't really i didn't
understand really
um you know it was only when i turned
pro i got a picture somewhere
my dad and my brother they were in the
game sixth day on the start line with me
you know there and
they were well received you know and all
of a sudden they must have really much
before
you know wow you know what the hell is
going on here you know
yeah great how about you just my parents
are there
my dad you know race and he would go
back
from belize he would race in mexico so
he had an understanding of it
um but yeah they were they they would
have rather me be been in almost any
place than
were where we lived so they were super
excited for me to kind of get up
and get out of uh get out of the area uh
so they're they're just excited they're
super supportive
as much as as they could be you know my
dad never raced
on a pro level so he couldn't tell me uh
what to expect or he couldn't
kind of equip me with some information
that i needed to to make the most of it
um but yeah they were they're like if
you're gonna
do the same thing that morris said it
was like if you're gonna do it if you're
gonna be protein you gotta go this is
gonna be a part of your life
or it's going to be a hobby so you you
go and you figure out if it's what you
want to do
yeah and did they come over to to the
continent to
watch you race or support you in any way
justin like
that was like one of the hardest parts
it's like my family being so far to what
far away i had i had no one
i was about i was i literally was by
myself um and that was going to be the
life
because my parents weren't going to
leave l.a i still i have two younger
brothers
um and all of my family's in california
so
they weren't going to leave they were
going to come over we didn't have
the money for them to come over and like
get a place and like
come support me so it was definitely
something that i was on my own with
yeah yeah i mean it's uh it's just a
ferry over from
from from dover for morris i guess in
that respect
let's let's look at some questions in
the chat that some people have asked as
we
move through this uh uh webinar one from
ken
um harris he says my question to
everyone what do you think are the
biggest obstacles
in raising awareness of cycling to a
more diverse audience and
increasing diversity in professional
cycling
um and what do you think we can all do
in order to help facilitate this quite a
big question there
should we tackle that one um what do you
think the biggest obstacles are in
raising
awareness of cycling to a more diverse
audience
okay um marlon i would say
sorry to in my opinion i would say
um they need role models you know they
they need people
um the the the community the ethnic
communities need to be able to associate
with
with with people who are who are winning
races so that's that's the
that's the way that's what it would be
you know and then if they see that and
they look at them and they say well look
he's doing it i could do this
yeah that's that's my opinion anyway
right that's exactly right it's it's
about seeing someone that
that is doing something in a way that
you would aspire to do it
right it's we talked about that earlier
with guys having kind of
mental lapses and breakdown on on the
upper level
of things and you're like oh man what
are we what are you showing them like
what are they
what are they getting excited about when
you watch someone score a goal
or you're watching a touchdown pass and
you see the lifestyle that they live and
then
and the like glory that that um that
person embodies
like we don't it's hard to find that
in cycling so it's like how do we how do
we get people to want to do this if
there's nothing uh inspiring them to
want to do it
so yeah
that would be wonderfully from if you
could make it over to the
uk you know and uh we would we would
have quite a few supporters i'm sure
you know that it would be amazing i love
i love coming over i love london it's
one of my favorite places so
and i understand that the the culture
that's there
um so i think it's important i think
it's important to come over like i know
it's a lot of pressure uh it's a lot of
pressure to to be the one that have to
to go get results and and understand
what it means to like
us as a people um but it's it's
something that's necessary like i'm
grateful to be able to like carry that
um and hopefully to continue to perform
um to make sure that you like you said
we have someone that people can look at
and go
oh well this guy's doing it like me and
corey like corey's doing it or i'm doing
it like
i can do it you know they look like me
they act like me they talk like me
you know what i mean they dress like me
all of those things matter it's the
whole representation matters like if you
don't see someone
that looks like you doing it that
carries themself like you doing it
why would you even think that you
couldn't think that it's possible
because it's not even it's not even
there to like aspire to
yeah so i mean does this is a question
for mark brown
um for you justin will will legion
consider a youth development opportunity
i don't know whether we have that
already going on in los angeles but is
that something that you might want to
develop more internationally a legion
youth development opportunity yeah it's
something that we you know
we're right now we're creating a
foundation it's been really
hard for me being a being the athlete
and also trying to develop the platform
for
to develop other people uh like me and
we're working on it but
it's it's extremely hard because you
know most of the time i'm trying to
focus
i'm juggling trying to focus on being
better every day so i can continue to
get results with also like
managing a team uh you know maintaining
inventory and all this other stuff
um but yeah we have we have a plan to at
least start to identify
and like we talked about earlier having
that um
having that um you know
opportunities uh with like day camp we
want to do junior day camps where we can
uh put a group of kids together and go
okay like let's see
how good these kids are and then like as
we see guys kind of stand out
then we'll create opportunities from
them with like you know that could be
you know funds to or grants to do like
national championships or big races
there's a big tour of a little bit of
bee that we want to put a composite team
together for
yeah so on and so forth you know
that sounds great
it sounds great and there's something
that i've actually spoken to morris
about the possibility of
of the morris spurts and scholarship in
the future who knows of
you know potentially um working with um
cyber industry um you know corporate
companies to establish something that
can
bring some equity to um
younger people from the inner cities
young black people from the innocent
cities to support them into the sport
with coaching with equipment
um is that something that um that we
could you know that
could be developed in the future morris
what do you think
um yeah it can be it could be done i
mean with the right backing
i mean yeah i'd love to do it you know
i've i've been trying over the years to
um with my with my little um
club team that i've got with the md
team dever you know from the bike shop
and um
we've tried to help i mean my son was
one of them and other other people
other people are you know women and
and and all young people we've helped
him along with the assistance from
from the import of kolnago from windwave
you know we've we've supplied them with
bikes with colonial bikes and um
you know they've um yeah a lot of them
have done well and moved on i mean
not not all of these were from ethnic
backgrounds you know but all the same
you know we we've helped
regardless of of their background if
they have the talent you know then then
we were
we've been happy to try and help them i
mean ethan
ethan hates her and his brother leo you
know even yeah
really else i mean he started he started
through you know with help from
with us with connaught you know he's he
he's a customer of us in the bike shop
you know and um we're very proud of him
where he's going and
i mean i helped my son you know with the
same thing i didn't he didn't get any
any um any and any special gifts you
know i told him you know you've got to
win a national championship before you
can ride a carbon bike
you know yeah no i mean you know i think
yeah i'd love to do it you know if but
you know obviously you know i would need
um i would need backing if i'm going to
do something
like that yeah i think i think it could
be done i think it could be done
and and you have you you still i know
through
diva cycles still help out with lots of
young champions in the community you've
mentioned even hater
um and his brother leo and they ride
really well for
um great britain and abby dentist was
another one of your
products as well so it's not just for
not just for black children but for
white um kids as well
that's the way to do it and talking
about role models um
in in cycling this guy here um gregory
borges just uh
just retired um a week or so ago
um were your impressions of his career
um um justin did you ever get to race or
meet
greg borge yeah it was i have one of his
jerseys one of his french long sleeves
i think one of the uh the world cups
were in the the carsonvilla velodrome in
in
la in california and uh i got introduced
to him by
by by my coach at the time um he was
super nice dude i think i traded him for
like a
like a kobe jersey for like one of his
french jerseys uh yeah because
you know i wasn't on a national team yet
but yeah i wanted to give them something
that was important to me that
represented like where i was from you
know and it was
it was really cool man like obviously he
was french but he like
he he looked like you know me
and and it was cool because yeah like i
want to be like i want to be like this
guy
and that's when track was massive in my
life at that point too so it was
it was really cool getting to just that
have that experience as a kid i think i
was like
i think i might have been 15 or 16 at
the time when i met him
uh and it had they had a massive impact
just meeting him
you know jersey was huge you know but
like just meeting him was it was
incredible so
he's a phenomenal athlete and i think
what i liked about um gregory bourget's
period in this point was the fact that
he was racing against
um chris hoy jason kenny and i think
you know by being the rival of those
british cyclists they just helped to
raise the bar
further and further for each other it
made track cycles so much
attractive um for me to watch and for me
to
be involved in as well when i went to
listen as well
morris have you ever bought some grocery
[ __ ]
his career in his um retirement did he
was
watching before he was before he was
after my time
um and um you know
to be honest with you um
yeah obviously i knew about him but the
coverage that
we had in the uk of um you know he
i mean to the average young person in
the in the uk if you mentioned his name
they wouldn't know
they wouldn't know you know who he was
or anything about
you know it wasn't it wasn't something
that was um
you know that was that was pushed if you
see what i mean yeah i was thinking
i went to go look for pictures of them
to post just pay my respects and like it
was
really hard to find like good quality
photos like like that story
wasn't told yeah this is it this is the
thing
you know i mean there is people out
there but if you don't
you don't dig you you don't know about
these people you know and um that's
that's the
that's the um that's that that's part of
the problem you know and
i mean if if you because you need i mean
a youngster
say at school could look at him and say
yeah you know i could do that you know i
want to do that
if they don't see it and they don't know
about it you know
that's what they need you know yeah
the fact about um gregory borge is that
he actually got into the sport um
as a cyclocross racer and won quite a
few races
as a cycle across race before he found
track cycling so
that shows you how versatile he was but
no you're right i mean
there's been a hundred there was a
hundred and ten year gap
um between gregory borgia becoming the
world's sprint champion to
this man major taylor major taylor won
his wild sprint championship in
1899 and borja won his first individual
sprint in 2009
and yeah i guess you know with the usa
and great britain
um when it comes to producing quality
black athletes
um usa and great brilliant can do that
in track and field we do it in boxing we
produce many
watch families in boxing between us who
are pretty much of the same physique as
people like bourget um i think um taylor
was
was a bit more slighter but what are the
issues as to why
the usa and gb have done nothing to go
looking for
this this talent what what do you think
morris
why why britain and the usa haven't gone
looking i mean i don't think
what you got to look at um
especially major taylor would would were
they looking for him or he found them
i think i think he found them i think
it's a bit
probably the same probably the same with
justin with me
they didn't look for me i found them you
see that's the difference
you know i mean i i knew you know what
from the time i got on a bike pretty
much from the first to the second day i
rode a bike i knew
and a matter of fact all it was was that
was
how how am i how do i get from being
where i am to where i want to go
you see and and i think major taylor was
them guys
he he knew it he knew he could do it he
just didn't know how to
you you know and that's what he got you
got there but um yeah
yeah you know it's a different
it's different from from some people who
will look at that and
and look at and say yeah you know i want
to i want to do that they they
that's why that's that's why there
hasn't been anyone in
and and they put up these barriers you
know there's there's barriers there
and um you know some people some people
some people will
will either bypass go around these
barriers or
climb over the barrier but some people
they see the barrier and they turn
around and go the other way
and that's it and the majority and
that's what happens
see yeah so i think i think i think what
you're saying maurice is it comes down
to attitude and
one of our viewers one of our listeners
wayne blythe
says that um about you a question for
maurice you may not have had a role
model
you um you could associate with when you
started racing but what made you want to
get into cycling and continue to do so
with all the barriers you came up
against okay
you started because you love cycling
like we all do
i was just going back there's a little
bit more there's a little bit more to it
than that
the truth is is that is that um
you know before i got into cycling
i don't think there was anything at
school we were never we were never
encouraged at school and
it was as if i didn't feel that i was
outstanding at anything and yet the
moment i got on a bike
i found you know what boy oh boy i can i
can do this i can i can be
you know there was nobody can and you
know what when you when you're a young
guy and at school you know that
they they i mean i used to be good at
technical drawing i was good at um
they strike the thing you know
engineering and yet
you know all they could point me in the
direction for
for was a cigarette factory you know and
i mean
you know i felt you know what i i just
you know when you
when i when i realized i could i could
ride a bike like that you know that
i thought you know what there's more
there can be a lot more to life than
for me than just working in a cigarette
factory
and you see um you see it was
it was to me it was a way out it was a
way it was a way
to to move forward and and that was that
was always the the incentive that i had
and
and from the beginning i you know i
looked at
i used to look at i remember my dad's i
remember 1969
eddie merks won the tour de france and
they used to show about 10 minutes of it
on the world of sport
and i watched it and i said to my dad i
said dad you see that man i want to be
like him
my dad turned to me he said you know if
you want to be like him you have to eat
steak every day and from that point i
said to my mum
i want steak every day yeah brilliant
story
you know that was that was um i mean i
i didn't have there wasn't any any black
roman at that point i didn't know about
major taylor i first learned about major
taylor in about 1972
when i was 16 years old but before that
i didn't know about any of these people
but i just looked at writers like mercs
especially him initially and then and
then the first magazine i ever bought
was was was
um he showed up it showed patrick serku
who was who was world's great champion
six day rider
and um and five years later there i was
racing with this guy
you see you know that was that was um
that was the incentive that was what
what drove me you know it was it was it
was that it was that i could make up
i could have a better life really milo
that's what that's what did it for me
that's good i guess i guess um it's it's
the question
as is as to whether it's intrinsic
motivation it comes from you as a person
to want to get into cycling or whether
that motivation can be triggered
extrinsically through
role models i mean justin does major
taylor still
um have a massive significance um
in inspiring black people to get into
cycling in the usa i mean
you know there's been majors headed
there's been nuts and vows there's been
um sean berharty i know that gideon
massey did a bit of sprinting
um that's still not not
a lot of black athletes um what what
what does it take for the usa to
um improve or increase diversity in
cycling
uh yes i think it just goes back to uh
having people that you know kids can
look up to i i learned
major taylor because i was on major
motions junior too
that's another way that we're going to
try to you know we're going to try to
attack
the the pro the the issue of like giving
more opportunities to kids like i raced
for a major motion
development team and while we didn't
have the best equipment there was some
stuff
passed around you know what i mean and
we want to bring that back we want to
bring that team back because
yeah my first stop in in in cycling when
i i
i think everyone learned how to most
people learn how to ride a bike
um and i knew i wanted to ride bikes
because you know i
it was a one day i played football and
basketball and someone was always
stronger
someone was always faster you know it
was always a battle
but when i when i raced bikes and when i
would ride bikes around i was always
faster than most people
so i was like this is the thing that i'm
like oh man like
i'm i'm usually there's like a battle
where like there's
i'm always looking for ways to be better
than than people but like on the bike
i'm just better than them
so that i started falling in love with
going fast from there and then like
starting to learn the history of like
you know my dad and him racing and my
uncle's racing and all that other stuff
and i was like okay there's something
here and this is not knowing anything
about the tour
i knew nothing about the tour until i
was maybe like 15
14 15. um but when i when i first
started the the club the the club that
was
um the club that was the support that
was had a lot of
the black community because it's pretty
small was the major motion cycling club
major taylor named after major taylor um
so yeah he was he was a hero for mine
from the beginning and and
as far as her song goes i got lucky
because rashaan acted more as an older
brother to me than like uh then like a
role model you know or like a
you know he's always an older brother
and mentor so i i looked at him
completely different even though he was
winning like a lot of the biggest races
in the country um so yeah i was i had a
unique experience there
um and then yeah from there i just you
know
it was it was again me chasing my own
ambition of like oh man like peruvian
looks
incredible being the world champion like
what does it mean to be the world
champion like
you know when you play football in the
nfl you win the
the championship you become the super
bowl you become the world champion but
it's not an international field or it's
like a slight
international field yeah so having that
knowledge and then looking at cycling
and being like oh no like this is
actually like
kirk like country versus country and
that i thought that was the coolest
thing in the world
um so i yeah going back to that i think
with the heroes like telling me stories
i know that like
i think heineken did a a story on major
taylor with
with like a recent one i think telling
the stories
but also having those as reference
while also going back and like having
people that are currently doing it
it's like what would like get kids and
get people
kind of stoked and inspired on on racing
bike racing yeah it's important to um
share the history of black excellence
in in cycling um from major taylor
through to
people like nelson valles uh even john
molding
south african road racer um to
people like
if those maurice of resources are out
there if there's books
magazines on social media then that
might be one way in which uh young
black people young asian people people
of color may want to come into the sport
but yeah it seems as though that you
that your particular
socialization and condition because you
because you had that legacy of major
taylor
had been part of major motion because
you had rashaam bahati as well
that that that seemed to give you a nice
um a nice sort of
advantage and um a sense of uh
belonging to the sport as well and and
but by the very fact that you're you're
um you're that your father and your
uncles are in a sport as well
brilliant brilliant i just thought right
we want to continue that that's why we
think that's what we try to do as much
as we can because
having access is important and we want
to give we want to grant that access so
we're going to take steps in making that
happen
yeah you're making it um real and true
for the next generation
you're passing on the baton and the
legacy i just um
there's going to be a time time for one
more question but before i do that i
just want to talk about
um a webinar um the next webinar that
i'm i'm
going to be conducting as part of this
series and that's going to be called
powerful young women
it doesn't come out very well on on this
slide but i'm going to be speaking i'm
going to be speaking with marie devin
kwame
french um junior world champion fight
for the 500 meters with charlotte cole
hussein
i'm a double british champion on the
track with rihanna paris smith
an aspirant sprinter right the team
terminator
and with danny khan the double junior
world champion talking about
their experiences in in
in the sport of cycling and how we can
aim to
inspire younger black women younger
asian women
younger women of color to come into the
sport and to enjoy it so that's going to
be
set for the seventh of february um um
from seven to eight
o'clock i'm looking forward to that
particular webinar
let me just um come back onto the screen
just like that and ask one more question
to both of you
um with regards to the future um justin
being based in los
angeles since um with the 2028 olympics
um planned for that city i know we have
you know we haven't
we've still got to go through tokyo of
course where it's going to happen or not
and we've got paris to go but
seven years of of planning for the los
angeles olympics
um how do you think um
[Music]
you know you could um be
involved in the development of of
cycling for that particular olympics and
how do you think
black-led grassroots organizations
could become more involved in that party
in 2028 i think it's a massive
opportunity right
it's a really cool opportunity that's
something that i work with the
the nonprofit outright and rasan has the
baha'i foundation those are massive
opportunities to go
talk to kids and get them excited on it
it's far enough away that if you get a
kid you know you catch a kid in like
the beginning of high school like they
they could they could
maybe be in that game it's enough time
to develop a writer
to do it so i think that it's something
to rally around and get excited about
and use not only what we're doing with
legion but also
dreams of you know who doesn't want to
be an olympian right i know
in australia in australia they go to
their track sprinters and say man you're
never going to beat usain bolt but you
might be able to be world champion on
the on the track and i think that's
something that we should maybe
take and go hey man like you know maybe
the nfl is not going to happen for you
you know we had we have an incredible
incredible amount of athletes here and
just maybe putting that on their door
and creating programs
uh where they can come in and at least
try maybe maybe you get
two percent you know that that group
that falls in love with the sport but
that could be significant and one of
those kids could change the future
forever
absolutely and um have you have you any
window any plans as to whether
track may be being built or what the
route may be um you know
maybe for the road race i dream about it
for the road racing for the uh
for the uh for the track i think they're
gonna do another track i'm not sure
uh we have a track but i think they're
gonna do another one because our track
is a little bit slow and everybody
complains about it
um but the road race course man there's
endless possibilities
you can do whatever you want you could
you take it up the coast and then
do a downtown circuit you could take it
into like griffith park i think there's
like talks about it being in long beach
because tour california was in long
beach but
i mean the possibilities are endless and
california is
massive man like you know yeah
l.a county is massive so we'll see i
would love to be involved
i don't know what the plans are i think
it's a little bit that's still a little
bit weight of the ways out
um but it's going to be really cool i
was riding through actually the old
olympic village the other day and it was
like it blew my mind
that it was like in the middle of
downtown you know you're like
close to hollywood and there's this
massive um
like apartment structure that they're
apartments now but
yeah that used that was a village and it
was really cool to kind of
it was really cool to kind of like have
that experience and and understand that
it's coming back so i think there's a
lot of
motivation there and i think that you
know if there's there's a lot of people
that can use that
uh to kind of help you know motivate
someone to to take that step it'd be
it'd be awesome
yeah be awesome if the national body
usac
could work with some of the local groups
in
local black groups in los angeles to
sort of really um
inspire young black people to get
involved in cycling because you know
that's quite a long period to sort of
work
with in order to maybe put one of those
guys
um on the number one of the podium for a
gold medal
and in the uk morris
um they're west to host the commonwealth
games
in birmingham 2022 and the world we had
the world
cycling championships in 2023 in glasgow
um in your minds you know
is there anything that you see that
maybe um you could do to help as an
ambassador or
whether any black led organizations over
here in the uk could work with british
cycling to
um improve um interest
from diverse groups to be honest with
you marlon i would
i would more go along with what justin
is saying that
um you know um you need to go to um
to the schools high schools i mean
and and identify and help
identify athletes but now
for for 2028 because
i mean you know unless unless there is
athletes who are already breaking
through now
then you know um you know you can't just
just grab somebody out of nowhere i mean
well you can but it's
it it's you know it's the possibilities
are very small whereas
if you look for 2028 and you start from
now
then i would say yes that that that that
is a
that is a that is a solid possibility
but you will have to start from now
and and along with the lines of what
justin was saying you know
i've always said this i mean you have to
go to the schools and there might be
some who are
who are good athletes but maybe not
quite there
in in say football or something like
that and and
you know there's been a lot of i think
even eddie marks played football at one
stage you know and it moved to cycling
you know and so
you know you could say okay it may be
maybe you're not going to make it with
manchester united but um hey you know
you why don't you try riding the bike
yeah and you might only be two percent
but then
you know yeah there's a good possibility
i think that's the way forward i think
so
yeah so seven years 20 20 28 is
is um is something that we hope to see
more
a broader range of faces doing cycling
at the olympic games not just
i mean as you know you mentioned the
commonwealth games and
but that's just around the corner you
know and i mean um you know i
unless they're already there winning
national championships now
and then then i i can't see how that's
gonna work you know but but um
i think you're gonna look look for 2028
is
is a is a more you know i think i would
hope that by then you know if if things
if if we it means that the federation
the british anyway from the british
point of view it would mean that the
british
british cycling would have to would have
to want this to work you know if they
want it to work it can happen you know
it can happen with
i'm i'm happy to help in what way i can
but
it's it's got to be down to them if they
want it to work
yeah i think that and like there needs
to be a lot of
listening right because in the way if
you want to make it work with athletes
from different cultures
you know doing in a way that works for
one culture it's not going to work
that's where
i found a lot of difficulty a lot of
difficulty in like wanting to be a part
of a lot of the things that go on in
cycling is that like it just doesn't
feel like you belong and
it's not your culture and it wasn't you
just don't it's hard to get attached and
feel welcomed into something like that
so i think that there needs to be a lot
of listening and growing
within yeah understanding
and understanding because as you're
bringing these different kids in these
different cultures you don't know what
their background is you can't accept you
can't expect them to just
you can't expect them to just uh come in
and do whatever you want without
listening to them the psychology of
what it is to be an athlete is extremely
important um and there's more of a light
being shined on it now but
uh i think that that's where you can
it's that's what's going to make or
break
if these these kids and these new people
that come into the sport uh
are successful are aren't yeah
so it's you let me try and sum up some
some of this it's about having
um a great presence of of ethnic
diversity in cycling
so that when you children or new young
athletes come into the sport they can
see their selves reflected
in that community um at a broad level
coaching level um even at race level
through
through commercials um being of
of color as well and i guess um for
people of color to come into the sport
it's um it
i guess it's a it can be an intrinsic
motivation but how can we
how can we also um inspire people to
come in through
through through role models that are out
there through advertising through the
media
there's so much to think about in order
to make
sport much more appealing to people of
color to black people to asian people
i'm gonna stop now i'm gonna say thank
you very much um
for your time this evening thank you
very much gentlemen it's been a
privilege
and a pleasure being with you today um i
wish you all the best with um
with your endeavors with legion of los
angeles
for the next few years justin is
fantastic
maurice um thank you for being with us
this evening is sharing
some of the excellent stories from from
your your um
career as well um i wish you all the
best i hope you're gonna be safe during
this covered
um pandemic and i hope to see you in
action
um as soon as possible so thank you very
much
for joining me in this webinar maurice
burton and justin williams thank you
very much
you